hi and welcome to this course called
excel from the beginning
in this course we're going to learn how
to use excel using
six projects that you can use in real
life so my name is chad sluter and i've
been a teacher for computer science and
computer applications for
several years what you're about to see
are applications that i've used in my
classroom
and have been successful with other
students in the past
so i really appreciate the opportunity
that free code camp has given me to
present this to you
i have used freed code camp in my own
classroom
with success with students from high
school to the university level
and so we're going to see a part of what
i've done in class and i'm glad to
contribute back
to help you as well let's take a look at
some of the projects that we'll build in
this course
so excel from the beginning is going to
use six projects the first one
and it'll be the most basic will be to
set up a payroll so imagine if you were
a company and trying to pay your
employees and keep track of their
overtime
so that's what we'll do in this first
project the second is
to set up a gradebook and so we'll be
doing computing on percentages we'll be
finding who's in the top of our class
and who's not
also we'll have a factor decision tree
factoring program
so we will try to decide what career
would be best based on what we prefer
what the pay is and other benefits of a
job and so a spreadsheet will help us
determine
how to make a decision another
application we'll create is a sales
database and so i will give you a bunch
of data and we will sort that we will
determine
who are the best sales people what their
commission is and make some charts
we'll also do what's called a car
inventory project where we'll create
what's called database actions we're
going to have a large number of
data again and we can show you how to
concatenate fields how to split them and
how to make reports with this
and then lastly i'm going to reserve
this section for
six different problems that we're going
to solve so the first
five projects are more tutorials to show
you how something is done
and then i'm going to give you some
challenge assignments at the end
where i give you a half of a solution
and then you use your creativity and
what you've learned in the previous
courses to see if you can solve the
problem
and so both we have a tutorial section
as well as a practice where you can put
things into service
now let's take a look at some of the
things you'll learn throughout here so
some of the terms
you'll learn from the very beginning how
to enter data how to navigate through a
spreadsheet
and how to save it also i'm going to
show you how to set up formulas because
using math formulas simple formulas to
solve problems such as how to compute
overtime
or how to compute the the percent that a
sales person should get on commission
or to simply do averages and to find the
maximums and minimums
so those are basic formulas we'll create
charts so you'll have pie charts and
line charts
and you'll have scatter charts excel is
very easy in creating charts you
basically have to choose what kind you
want
and it does it for you also we're going
to do excel
with some more advanced features so
relative
and absolute references is used if you
have some kind of a factor that you want
to use in
other parts of the spreadsheet and so
that's another feature that we'll see
we're going to do imports and exports of
data so csv
is a common file you find on the
internet so maybe your bank statement
comes to you in the mail or at least
online i guess
and it says we produce these items in
csv format as
if you know what cse format is so i'll
show you how to use this and so you can
interface with other programs on the
internet
we're using something called vlookup so
vlookup is a powerful tool
that is like searching through a menu to
find the right item for your choice
also we're going to use pivot tables
pivot tables are
summary reports so if you have a large
amount of data and you want to condense
it to a very readable decision
this is kind of a big data tool so the
last one is to split text and
concatenate text and so you can
modify things according to how you want
them to be
so that's some of the features that were
ahead of us if this looks interesting to
you then please let's continue on with
the first lesson
so here's the first lesson we're going
to work with something called payroll
and you can see that we're going to set
up a group of employees
we're going to give them some fake
numbers their hourly wage
and calculate once again with fake
numbers
how many hours they worked then we're
going to take those numbers
and use some simple formulas to fill in
these columns of data where we can see
how much they get paid
also i'll show you shortcuts so that
large numbers
of columns and rows get rather tedious
but there are shortcuts in excel to make
it work fast so let's get started with
our first lesson
ever in excel so this particular lesson
on excel the beginning parts of how to
use excel has been seen
over a million times on my youtube
channel so welcome if you haven't seen
it before
this is a great way to start using excel
we're going to use
excel to create a spreadsheet for our
business
we're going to launch the program and
start a blank workbook
now since this is the first assignment
that we're going to do with microsoft
excel
we need to go through some of the things
that you see in any spreadsheet
first of all a spreadsheet is designed
in organized according to cells
just like in the game battleship where
you have columns that are letters and
rows that are numbers you can
identify cells such as this one by such
as
g6 to enter in
information into a cell you simply click
it and start typing
and so i'm going to type employee
payroll
press enter and you notice that this
cell
even though it extends into column b
really it is only in
a1 now let's use excel as a payroll
we're going to keep track of the hours
that our employees worked this week
and we'll keep track of their wages so
first of all
we need to put some column headings in
so i'm going to put in the title
last name and then first name and then
i'm pressing tab between these
keys so that it moves the selection
moves to the right
hourly wage and then
i'm going to put in the date let's say
january 1st and press
enter over here i'm going to say that
this
is the hours worked
and this is their total pay so i'll just
put the word pay
now you notice you can expand a column
by clicking between the column headers
like between d
and e now you can see the whole word
the next thing you need to do is you
need to invent some names so you get to
come up with about 20 names maybe 15 for
your employees
i'll type them in now now you can see
that i've invented names
last names and first names and now i'm
going to give them an hourly wage
each person makes about 15 or so
so i'll type in some numbers here you
notice when you type in numbers they are
right justified
when you type in the person's name in
your spreadsheet
that they're all left justified that's
just a convention that microsoft excel
uses so that you can identify
letters versus numbers
now one of the items that you will most
commonly use in excel
is formatting these are all hourly wages
i'm going to select this range with my
mouse by clicking and dragging
the first square is actually highlighted
even though it's white the other ones
are gray
but what i want to do is change them
into a currency so i'm going to click on
the dollar sign up here
and you notice that they all become
dollar signs
they all are the hourly wage for each
employee
now let's invent a number for each of
the employees for how
how long they worked the average work
week for a full-time person is about 40
hours
so i'll create wages or i'm sorry i'll
create
the number of hours that each person
worked in this column
after giving each employee a number of
hours we're going to start working with
formulas now
over here on this line this square in e4
i'm going to create a calculated number
a calculated cell
if a person gets 15.90
an hour and they work for 40 hours
how much do they get paid well
fortunately the calculations in excel
are quite easy to do
on my keyboard i'm going to press the
equal sign
and you notice up here in this area
called the formula bar
we have an equal sign as well as the
equal sign in the cell
now i'm going to click on the cell that
has the
wage in it 1590. when i click there
the letter c4 is entered into the
formula bar
c4 is the wage fifteen dollars and
ninety cents
now i want to multiply fifteen ninety so
i'm going to press the shift and the
eight key
which is the multiply sign and then i'm
going to click the forty
the doll the number of hours that this
person worked
so my formula is equals to c4
times the number that's in cell d4
when i press enter it'll tell me that
this person gets
636 dollars if you go and change some of
these numbers such as
if we added an hour here and i type 41
and press
enter the calculation is automatically
updated
when you double click on a cell that has
a formula you will see that the colors
correspond to the cells that you clicked
so
c4 is in blue which is this number
and d4 is in red i'm going to press
enter again
and it shows the numbers again
microsoft excel has a nice feature where
you can copy and paste
formulas if i right click on this cell
and choose copy
and then i click on the next cell and
choose paste
it'll automatically calculate the next
line
you can also highlight a range
and choose right click and paste it will
fill down where all of those numbers are
why is this one looking
look like railroad tracks or a bunch of
pound signs it's because the value
is actually too large to be held in this
in this cell
so i need to make the column a little
bit wider
and now it becomes visible another way
to fill down
if you want to you can go to the corner
of a cell
where there's a little green dot and if
you click
exactly on the corner and drag your
mouse down
it will also fill down the values in
that column
and so now i've quickly calculated the
pay for every single employee
one more thing we're going to do with
this formula
is we're going to add a few lines at the
bottom
i want to know who is the maximum press
enter who is the minimum press enter
what is the average pay
and what is the total pay these numbers
max
min average and total are just labels
but over here in this column i'm going
to put in a corresponding formula
microsoft excel has hundreds of formulas
that are predefined
here's one of them you type in the equal
sign
and then you type the word m-a-x you
notice that these
automatically are drop-down menus that
show that
this is one of the formulas that excel
knows about
after typing max i use the open
parenthesis which is
the shift key in nine and
i'm going to drag my mouse across a
range of cells
until i come to the very top release the
mouse button
and press shift and 0 to do a close
parenthesis so what this will do it will
give me the maximum
of all of these cells the maximum person
is getting dollars an hour and so you
can see in this line here that
trent man is making 45 an hour
now i'd like to know who the minimum is
so i'm going to do the same process type
equals sign m-i-n
open parenthesis and drag my mouse
across
our range and i will tell it what the
minimum is
after i press shift and 0
enter and the the lowly person in my
office is getting six dollars and ninety
cents
that looks like it's paul smith now
what's the average employee
well i can type in equals and then av
and you see there's a bunch of formulas
for average i just want this most simple
one i'm going to choose
average
i'm going to select the range
close parentheses and press enter
the average employee makes 16.48
okay let's take this range here
of three different formulas highlight it
right click it with the mouse copy it
now i want to click in the next column
over right click
and paste and now you see
that we have the maximum the minimum
and the average for the number of hours
that are being worked
now you notice that these values are
listed as dollars they're actually not
dollars
their number of hours that the persons
are working
so i want to change these formattings
back to
general numbers up here in the ribbon
where you will find the number
formatting area there's a small
arrow that if you click it will bring up
a dialog box that shows all different
types of formatting
for numbers i'm going to select general
and click ok
now why does this number have so many
decimal places in it
it's because it's because we are
computing an average
it would be nice if we would just round
these off to maybe the
tenth the tenths place or the hundredths
place
so let's go to these zeros here and
we're going to
decrease the decimals that we're
rounding to
so to the nearest tenth is good enough
for us so now we have the number of
hours
maximum minimum and average for our
employees here in column d
for column e we could also find the min
the maximum the minimum and the average
as well
so let's highlight this group i'm going
to
select this bottom right corner drag to
the right
and it fills to the right now and shows
me that these are the
maximum dollars that someone made the
minimum dollars and the average
once more these are dollars figures
these are not ours so let's
change these to the dollars format so
i'm going to click up here on the dollar
sign
and now we have the average the maximum
and the minimum
in the salary for this set for this week
so now we've created the maximum the
minimum and the average for each of
these columns columns
c d and e we haven't done anything yet
with a total
for the total let's find out what the
total number of hours worked was
and let's find out what the total number
of wages that we've paid is
so for the word sum we type equals s-u-m
and that will give us the total let's do
shift in nine
and then i'm going to select a range
here
i'm going to select all of the hours
worked
close parenthesis and enter and you'll
see that there were 695 hours worked in
my shop
now i'm going to fill this to the right
and shows that i made a lot of more paid
a lot of money
for my wages this week i'm going to
change this to a dollar sign format
and it shows now eleven thousand five
hundred and thirty two dollars
the last thing we should do is put our
name at the top so maybe c1 is a good
place
type in your name press enter save the
spreadsheet
print it and you're done with the
assignment number one for excel
welcome to assignment number two for
microsoft excel
we're going to extend assignment number
one using the payroll spreadsheet that
we had created earlier
what i'd like to do in this assignment
is add a new formula
using the if formula and also adding the
idea of paying
overtime to our employees so you notice
here in column d
that we have the number of hours that
each employee worked
the first employee worked 41 hours we're
going to give him a bonus for his extra
hour of overtime
so i'm going to start by inserting a
column here in column e
if i click the column header the entire
column is selected
i can right click on the column header
and choose the insert button
and it will now give me a new column to
work with
the first column column d was the hours
worked now i'm going to say this is the
overtime
hours the overtime hours
is a calculated field so let's come up
with a formula that will tell us how
many
hours extra that this employee worked at
first it would seem simple we would just
say equals
the number of hours the person worked
subtract 40
and that will tell us how many hours of
overtime this person has
it works great if you have 41 but
there's some errors
if you have less than 40. i'm going to
fill the column
down and you will see that when we come
to paul
smith in row number eight he actually
gets a negative one hours
it's a negative hours that he's worked
that doesn't seem to work too well
what we would rather give is paul should
have zero
hours of overtime not a negative number
so let's revise the formula a little bit
so let's go up to here and this time i'm
going to type in an equal sign
with the word if if is a command that
says let's take
a logical test and we will
a logical test is either an equal sign
greater than or less than
and then we'll give it a value depending
on if that test is true or not
and if it's false we'll give it a
different number watch how this works
the question is if his hours worked
is greater than 40 and a comma
the value if it is greater than 40
should be
his hours worked minus 40
a comma and if he worked less than 40
hours
then let's just give him zero for this
column which would be zero hours of
overtime
a close parenthesis and press rest press
return
so he still gets one hour of overtime
but now when i fill the formula down you
see that the people that worked
less than 40 hours gets zero in their
form in their formula instead of
negative numbers and so this is the
correct formula for calculating
overtime pay now
how about the pay what does that do
let's go back and review this fear if i
double click here
you will see that this formula takes the
number of hours to the hourly wage and
fills it in column f that's great but
now we give them a bonus for working
overtime
so let's create create a new column and
call it
overtime bonus now in this formula
we're going to calculate a bonus for the
number of overtime hours they worked
so i'm going to say equals 0.5
and use the time sign 0.5 times their
hourly wage so we're going to give them
half of their hourly wage
times the number of overtime hours they
worked
what that does is it gives us a formula
to give them
time and a half or one and a half times
for each hour
that they worked overtime press enter
so since john kern earned
one hour of overtime we give him his
full 41 hours of pay
plus an extra 50 of his pay
for one of those hours let's fill this
down
and see what we have for the rest of the
people
some of the people have zero this one
got no
extra time bonus because he worked 39
hours
some of these people worked 40 hours and
still got zero time why
because the formula is about how many
hours beyond 40 that we're calculating
so they got paid their full wage for the
first 40 hours
now how about the total pay
let's put in a new column the total pay
is simply
equals to their regular 40 hours of pay
plus their overtime bonus and a return
and let's use the fill down option
some of the numbers are too big so we
will expand the column
and this is their total pay down here at
the bottom we calculated maximums
minimums averages and totals
for all of these formulas let's move
these to the right
calculate the totals now and see we can
see
what everybody earned including their
overtime
welcome to assignment number three with
microsoft excel
what you see on the screen before you is
a final version
of the payroll spreadsheet you notice
that it's got a lot of cells
don't worry most of these are copied and
pasted
it's an extension of assignment number
one and two
in the gray area here where you see
hours worked
in the previous assignments we only were
concerned with one week of pay
and this assignment we're going to add
four more weeks of pay
and we we will use calculations to find
out how much they earned
their overtime bonus and then here in
the blue area
their total pay so we'll start from an
assignment here that we did before and
we'll simply extend it
to look like the one that you just saw
well first of all what we need to do is
add some new columns
so starting in column e i'm going to
right click
and choose insert i'm clicking on the
column header
let's do this a few times and will give
us some space to work with for
other weeks in the month
now starting here in column e3 i'm going
to add
seven days to this date notice the first
date that we chose was january 1st
you can either type in january 8th for
the next week or we can use a
calculation
let's use a calculation i'm going to say
this equals
this square d3
plus seven and now it starts at january
eighth
now if i use the fill command i'm going
to create
several more columns and they're
automatically calculated
next i'm going to invent some more hours
these are numbers that should be
approximately 40. they can be a little
less they can be a little bit more
but it doesn't matter really what the
numbers are just so that we have some
data to work with
for each employee now we've reached the
end
of our data for the number of hours for
each employee
it looks like i've created one extra
column here in column i
so i'm simply going to remove it by
choosing right click on the column
header
and delete
now let's go to the overtime hours i'm
going to put a date here for the week
january 1st and once again i'm going to
insert some columns
you can actually insert columns more
than one at a time if you highlight
four column row headers and choose
insert
you get four new rows once again i'd
like to
add seven to the date that's in january
first
this plus seven
and fill to the right
now let's add some overtime hours now i
want to calculate the hours of overtime
for each week
well we've already done this in the
previous assignment with this famous
if formula if d4 is greater than 40 then
give us the value d4 minus 40 otherwise
give us 0.
i can take this entire block and copy it
i'm going to right click on it choose
copy
and i'm going to right click on the next
square and choose paste
so now it's calculating the overtime
hours for the week of january 8th
let's double click on this cell and you
notice that
we are now calculating the overtime
hours from this blue square
the 42 hours from january 8th so the
formula automatically adjusted
for the column letter this is using
cell e4 i'm pressing escape now
double clicking on this one and you
notice that this cell was using
the cell d4 as its source for its
numbers
so when you copy and paste excel
automatically assumes
that you are relatively addressing
columns somewhere else
in the spreadsheet so if this is one
cell to the right
then the next one is one cell to the
right
i'm going to copy and paste again so
i'll copy this row here
copy and paste it
cop and paste again
and paste again
so now we have overtime hours calculated
for every week
now when you start to get a lot of cells
on a spreadsheet it can get confusing
looking at so many numbers so excel
allows us to paint the cells in certain
colors
these cells here that i'm highlighting
now are all
related to the number of hours that they
worked
let's give them a color let's paint them
all something gray
so now you can see that they all belong
together as a block
for overtime hours let's paint them a
different color let's choose you can
choose whatever color you like but i'm
going to choose some kind of a
salmon color
and now we're going on to calculate
their pay
this pay here really is the pay for
january 1st
so the week of january 1st is what they
got paid here
now i'm going to calculate the pay for
every week
so let's insert about
how many three more columns
and let's do once again equals the
previous date plus seven
and then fill that formula to the right
looks like we need one more column
i'll fill this one to the right
now how did we calculate pay
we simply took two numbers from their
hours
and the wage hours worked
which was 41 times their wage
we're going to find something new here
if we just simply copy and paste
these formulas we're going to get the
wrong results i'll show you what happens
in a minute
i'm gonna copy this formula paste it for
the next week
now why in the world is everyone making
over a thousand dollars some up to three
thousand three hundred
what happened well let's double click on
this cell
and find out where it's coming from
first of all you notice it's very
difficult to see the other side of the
world here
we can actually zoom out on a
spreadsheet
and we can make it easier to see the
whole page so let's zoom out to
50 percent
we can see the whole spreadsheet now but
the numbers are a little small
let's choose something else i'm going to
select the part that i'm interested in
just these cells click on zoom
and choose fit selection that will fit
this highlighted area
on the screen so now i can see hourly
wage
all the way to the last formula okay now
let's go look in this cell here
what's going on in cell number o
four it says take the
cells d4 and multiply by e4 and give me
the results
d4 and e4 that worked great while we
were in the previous week we were taking
the hourly wage
times the number of hours well now the
relative referencing
is saying well let's take the first two
cells and multiply them together
so we need to make a modification this
actually should be referencing
c4 i'm pressing escape on the keyboard
and i'm going to delete all of this here
i'm going to right click on these
and choose clear contents
what i need is what's called absolute
cell referencing so i'm going to modify
my original formula here
it's telling me in this formula that we
should use c4
times d4 and i know that i'm going to
copy it to the right four times
what i really want to do is keep
referencing the hourly wage because
that's how you calculate
pay hourly wage in c4
times the number of hours worked which
is going to be d e
and f and g and h so is there a way to
tell excel
not to use relative referencing instead
absolute referencing that's what we're
going to call it anyway
i'm going to go up to this formula bar
and modify
the letter c i'm going to simply type in
a dollar sign in front of it
that doesn't mean a value dollars it
just means that
every time that you think about cell c
or c4
you're going to always use column c
for the first week nothing changes all
of the numbers should stay exactly the
same
but now when i copy this range of cells
and paste it into the next column
let's take a look at what this reference
is i'm going to double click here
you notice that it is still referencing
cell c4
but now the other cell is relative
referencing
it says let's move to the right one
every time and so it's now
multiplying the hourly wage times the
hours from january 8th
or the 42. i'm pressing escape on the
keyboard
now i'm going to highlight this whole
range
this time i'm going to instead of copy
and paste i'm just going to use the fill
right
option using the little square in the
bottom right corner
it feels right and all of the wages are
calculated let's double click here
you see it's using their proper range
its number of hours in this case is 30
but it's still referencing
c4 and so now they're overtime i'm sorry
their their regular pay work
is all calculated correctly well let's
give this range
a separate color as well this is our
regular pay
so i'm going to highlight this section
here
go back to home and choose a color from
the bucket let's see this time i like
green
green for pay let's move to the right a
little bit
now we need to calculate their overtime
for each week
their overtime pay well we've done that
for the first week but
we need to have some more weeks so let's
insert
four new columns choose the insert
command
let's put in a date for each of these
columns this one was january 1st
this one's going to equal the first cell
plus 7 and then
fill it to the right
and so we have all of the weeks for
january
once more this is going to be a problem
if we don't have
absolute cell referencing right now
the overtime pay is correct for the
first week
if we fill this to the right we're going
to have a problem
we're going to have numbers that are way
too high like this one if i double click
here
you see it's referencing over time hours
but way back at the beginning it is
referencing
not the wage that we're expecting it's
cell d4 so we're going to have to change
this formula to use
absolute cell referencing again so i'm
going to
clear these highlight choose clear
contents from the menu
i'm going to double click on this
formula
and instead of c4 i'm going to reference
it as dollar sign
c4 and
i'm going to copy this formula all the
way through the block
here's another way to copy and paste
through the entire block i'm going to
copy just one cell
then highlight the entire place where i
want to use this cell
and choose paste
and all of the formulas now show
the overtime bonus formula for each week
okay the last thing we should probably
do is give this its own color
so let's use the overtime pay as a color
such as i don't know
let's pick something red something blue
how about blue blue is looking good
now for the total what in the world is a
total going to look like
first of all i need to zoom out a bit
let's go to zoom to
50 percent
total wages well the total wages right
now
is calculated using it looks like
pay plus the overtime bonus
looks great let's put in a date over
this this is going to be january 1st
and once more we need to calculate
equals
this cell plus seven
and we're going to use a few more weeks
of this
now this time we should be able to get
away with using
relative cell referencing if i highlight
this
and i'm filling to the right
i'm going to double click on the cell
titles so that they
all adjust to the proper width
now let's check this one out if i double
click on this cell what's it adding
together
looks like it's adding the pay from the
first
no from the second week times the
overtime bonus for the second week
that's exactly what we wanted let's see
try another one here i'm going to pick
this one
randomly choose one cell it looks like
it's adding
the proper cells so in this case we
don't want
absolute cell referencing the usual
default settings for
relative referencing work just fine
let's add one more color
and we'll call it a day let's go to
a darker gray one more thing that you
might want to do
is use the formulas across the bottom
i'm going to actually highlight this
section here
and fill it all the way to the right
we calculate the
totals the maximums the minimums for
every week
one more thing you might want to add
here is the total pay for
all weeks let's say january pay
and i'm going to put in s
equals sum formula equals sum
and then add up all four of these
five of these with a close parenthesis
let's zoom in a little bit so you can
see better
double click again so we're adding up
all five weeks that were paid in january
and then let's fill this down for
everybody
you can see now who is the top
pay earner in the company i'm going to
copy this range
paste it over here
the maximum person is this one earned
eight thousand dollars this month that
looks like this line right here
second from the last employee let's
scroll to the left and see who that is
second to the last employee
the name is trent man
now when you print you're going to have
a difficult time fitting all of this on
one page
fortunately excel gives us a nice way
to print all things on one sheet let's
go to the file menu
and choose print
now down here it says no scaling we are
actually
using five different sheets of paper to
get everything printed
it's going to be very wasteful don't do
that
first of all we can turn the paper
sideways so let's change the orientation
to landscape
that helps a little bit now it's only
four pages wide
it says scaling here we can say this we
could fit all of the columns
on one page or fit all the sheet in one
page let's try that
okay it's very small seems to work
though
let's save it and print it as this size
the next lesson we're going to do is
called gradebook and you can see that
the gradebook is not just
a simple gradebook but we're going to
show what's called conditional
formatting that's what those little
colored dots are
they're going to show who are the top
students in your class and who are the
bottom
we're going to do percentiles as you can
see on the right side and so
several things about a grade book and
formatting data that we haven't done
before
and you'll have a very nice looking
chart when you're finished
what you see on the screen in front of
you is a grade book for our employees
we're going to give them a series of
tests for the company
a safety test a company philosophy test
financial skills test and a drug test
and then we will give them
employment based on their testing level
so let's assume these are all new
employees
and they are testing after their job
interview
so this is the completed spreadsheet
let's start from scratch
and build it one place at a time
so i'm going to file and choose new and
a blank
workbook let's start by giving this a
title
in the first cell let's call it grade
book and we're going to keep people's
names in here so we'll put last name
here and first name
now you can see that i've typed in the
names of the employees that i used from
my payroll spreadsheet
you can just copy and paste these names
in or if you like to retype different
names you can
but we're going to use up to line number
20 for those that are going to be taking
the company test
now you notice that i put the titles of
each test
in c1 d1 e1 and f1
the first test is called safety test the
next one is called the company
philosophy test
the third one is the financial skills
test and then finally the
drug test notice that these words all
run into each other
let's do a format on these cells to make
them fit better
i'm highlighting all four cells and up
here on this button
it's called orientation i click it and
let's choose rotate text
up and now each of these cells
is written vertically so it allows us to
make the columns narrower
now how much is each test worth
let's fit in here in b2 and let's put in
here points possible
this will show us what the maximum grade
is for each of these
let's say the first one is worth ten the
next test is worth twenty points the
financial test is worth a hundred
and the drug test we're just going to
have as a pass or fail so it is worth
one point
notice that i need to make the column e
a little bit wider because 100
doesn't fit in the square very well now
all we have to do next is starting with
john kern is
invent a number how many points did john
earn and so on
now you can see that i've entered
numbers for every one of my employees
so the maximum is 10 nobody has more
than 10 points do they oh trent man got
an 11
but then over on this side where it says
drug test you notice that everybody has
a one or a zero so there are two
employees that got zeros that means they
failed their drug trust
next let's calculate the percent that
they earned for each of these tests
i want to take the titles and copy them
so i'm highlighting all four of these
right click on one of them and choose
copy and let's put them in the next
area over how about column h we'll start
with column h
now what would be the formula for a test
and the percentages well you would take
the
equals and we'll take this number 10
and divide it by the points possible
divided by 10 and press enter this turns
out to be a one
actually i want it to say one percent so
i'm going back to the
ribbon and choosing the home tab and
you'll find in here they're formatting
for percentages there's a percent sign
so on the safety test john kern
earned 100 percent now i'd like to copy
and paste this formula so that
all the percents are shown for this
assignment
let's just fill it down and see what
happens
now there's a problem this one says
divide by zero error
this one says eighty percent this one
says ninety
ninety percent no this one says 100 it
should say 90. so it's not working like
we
thought it would let's double click on
this 100 percent
do you see what's being divided it says
take c7
and divided by c5 really what we want to
do is take c7
the score that wendy received and
divided by the points possible and so
this error
is what's called a relative referencing
error it's
counting back two cells and dividing by
two cells above it
we need to use absolute referencing here
to get the correct results
so i'm going to clear these and try
again going to right click and choose
clear contents
what i really want is to take equals
the cell here of the points that john
earned
and divided by this number with an
adjustment
i want to absolutely choose
row number two every time so i'm going
to put a dollar sign in front of two
and so now when i fill down it's going
to always
reference row two for all of these
assignments
and so indeed we get the correct answers
there is 110 percent listed here
that is correct because trent earned in
11 points
now i should be able to just copy and
paste these cells
or use the fill command and calculate
all of these numbers immediately
notice the drug test is either one
hundred percent
or zero percent and so now even though
the tests are all worth different points
we scored each of them with percentages
now it would be nice to tell at a glance
which of these
students or which of these employees is
doing extremely well and which ones
are failing let's highlight a set of
test scores let's do the first one here
and i'm going to do conditional
formatting
conditional formatting will color the
cells according to the numbers that are
inside
so on my ribbon i look for conditional
formatting
and in this case i'm choosing icon sets
this set here is like a set of traffic
lights it's got red
yellow and green and then a black one
automatically it puts an icon based on
who's in the top set percentages and
who's in the bottom
and so you can see that the green lights
show up immediately
with the top test scores there's a red
light for somebody that's
failing and then there's a black one for
an absolute miserable score
of five let's try that with the next row
let's highlight the next set and we'll
choose conditional formatting
and icons and choose the traffic lights
again
and make the box a little bit wider
so you can see once again that karen is
having difficulty she received a six
on the company philosophy tests
you have to do these all individually
because each one of them has its own
set of scores
if you try to format them all at the
same time you'll get different results
choose the traffic lights again for our
financial skills test
and see who sorts to the top
this time you notice right away there's
a black line or a black dot on blessing
she's not so good at financial skills
and for the drug tests the last one we
will format it again
under icons and feel free to experiment
with the others there's color scales and
there's data bars
interesting things you can see on each
of them we're just using icons for these
and so now we have little traffic lights
showing us
quickly who is doing well you can see
there's four green lights for john
there's some people that have mixed
results in between
now let's also make a rule that we want
to sort out people that receive less
than
50 percent on any test so a quick way to
find out who that is
would be to highlight all of the test
scores and the percentages
let's go back to conditional formatting
now here's a nice option the first one
called highlight cell rules
let's choose the one that says less than
so in this and we want to find out who
is receiving less than and let's put in
so i can put 0.5 in here and then the
options here are light red filled with a
dark red text you can choose different
options but we'll just leave it as the
first
and click ok and right away you can see
that
at a glance there are some people that
have problems
less than fifty percent for karen
less than fifty percent on a drug test
means you failed it you got zero
less than fifty percent on financial and
so we have a few of these people
that are problematic now since i have a
concern about who should be fired
i'd like to create a another line called
fire employee with a question mark
and then we're going to say should we
fire them or not
we're going to use a formula that asks
this question are
any of these scores less than fifty
percent
if so then we should fire them you
should at least pass with fifty percent
so the formula we're looking for is
called the or formula
you type the equal sign and type or
or in a parenthesis this means that
we're going to ask a series of logical
questions is some number less than
another one
and if so then we're going to return
true watch this
i'm going to say or is this
score here the safety test less than 0.5
and i'll put a comma and then i'll ask
another question
is i-4 less than
50 percent another comma
is this less than 0.5 and then finally
the question is
is comma is this one
less than 0.5 so i have four questions
in a row
all of them ask the same thing is this
number less than 0.5
and if i press enter it says false
none of these scores are less than 0.5
however when i fill down you will see
that some of these scores
are less than 0.5 here's a true and a
true and a true
once more we can see from this side
from this line who should we fire who
should we dismiss
let's do a conditional formatting on
this one
let's go highlight the cells choose
conditional formatting
and this time i'm going to ask the
question is it equal to
is this question equal to
true i can spell true correctly
and press enter and so now all the ones
that are true are highlighted in red
so we know who we should fire
lastly let's put some numbers at the
bottom of the chart
let's go down to here and use our famous
for
max min average
let's just use three max min and average
so in this cell we ask equals this
is going to be the maximum of the range
that's above it
so maximum of all of these scores
with a parenthesis and let's do the same
for minimum
equals min a parenthesis and we'll ask
about all of these
parentheses what is the average score
equals average and then
the cell range
and then we can use the fill right
option show what the average
is for each of these
i'm going to copy all these
and put them on the other side where the
percentages are
now since these are percentages it would
make sense to format them with a percent
sign
let's create a chart that shows all the
graphs
of each of these scores from
the safety test i'm going to highlight
safety tests
and now let's go to insert
let's choose a chart here's called a
column chart
in the column chart we'll just click it
and we'll choose
clustered columns
and slide it over to the side now
we're missing some things on it we need
a chart title
double click where it says title we can
change it to call it
safety test
we also need to know who are the people
taking the test we just have numbers at
the bottom
so it'd be nice to change that after we
have the graph on the screen it would be
nice to show the actual names of the
people
as well as the numbers or instead of the
numbers
right here we just have employee numbers
at the bottom
let's right click on the graph and
choose select data
now when it says here horizontal axis
labels let's change that
let's edit that now it's asking us what
is the
label range it's asking us for a range
of cells we can either type it in
or we can just simply go over here and
click on
kern and drag down to underhill you
notice as i do that
it's telling me that from sheet 1 the
range a4 to a20 is going to be used
and click ok and click ok
again and so now you see all the
people's names at the bottom
so we've created a test graph the safety
test
let's do another graph let's do the
company philosophy test
so highlight the scores go up to the
insert button
or the insert options and let's choose
another chart another column chart
and slide it down below this one
let's give it a new title
let's call it the company philosophy
test
once more we need to add these labels in
so that they are the names instead of
the numbers so let's choose
select data where it says access labels
we'll edit that
and we need to slide over to select the
people's names
so from underhill up to kern
and okay okay
let's close this menu here and you can
see the company philosophy test
one more graph the financial skills test
let's create that one same process
insert go to charts and choose a column
chart
give it a name
and let's give the names at the bottom
something instead of numbers
and let's slide this one in place below
the other two
okay that brings us to the finish of
this of this gradebook test
let's save our document and print it
once more when you print
be careful that you don't print on
thousands of pieces of paper
that says we're using six so maybe i'm
exaggerating
let's change a few things let's
orientate it so it's sideways
let's see if we can fit this to one's
one page
once you have one page listed here you
can see all the graphs
neatly arranged and your data on the
left side
you're ready to print in this lesson
called decision maker we're going to
create
a scenario where you're supposed to pick
a job and we're going to weigh
different factors based on your opinion
so pay
the amount of jobs that are out there in
the job market how much you enjoy it
how reliable the job is to you and
various factors
and then based on your opinions excel
will give you an
answer on what career you should choose
welcome to excel assignment number five
this is a decision chart that we're
going to create using microsoft excel
let's assume that you're going to choose
a career based on several
factors we're going to consider several
jobs here on the column a
and several factors that would lead you
to decide to go into that field such as
your pay in that job the job market
which would mean the
likelihood that you'll be hired the
enjoyment factor how well do you like
this job
your talents how well are you at doing
the job
and then finally another factor might be
schooling how much time
is invested to get to this career and so
we'll create a
chart that will lead you to a decision
that probably is one of the most
important in your life is
which career are you going to work at so
let's start from scratch i'm going to
choose a new workbook
a blank one and let's start by giving it
a title let's call it
career decisions
now down here we're going to call this
the the job column and
you invent some jobs that you think you
might do
so i've placed a few jobs here in column
a from mcdonald's manager to an nfl
player
now that's a large variety of types of
things that you could possibly
choose you might have different ones now
let's put in the factors that would lead
you to
decide on one of these obviously pay is
an important factor
i've placed other factors into the chart
as well not only pay but
job market the enjoyment your talents
and your schooling that's required
so now under the column pay let's assume
that
a five or some number large is
the best that you can do in the career
and a one is the worst
so a mcdonald's manager let's put him
down at near the bottom
a doctor's probably doing pretty well
let's give him a four
nfl let's assume is the best it's a five
engineers probably pretty good as a
three
and a truck driver might be a three as
well
and then for the others job market uh
likely they probably can get a job there
a doctor once you get your school you're
probably guaranteed a job
nfl probably the worst of the factors
because hardly anyone gets that
gets to that level engineers they've got
very good job prospects and truck
drivers apparently are doing well as
as well how well would you enjoy doing
the job
maybe mcdonald's not so much doctor if
that's your passion
so make up some numbers based on your
own preferences
and so i filled in each of these
categories based on
what i think about each of the each of
the each of the factors
now it would be simple just to sum up
the
lines here so i'm just going to put sum
and then add up all of these together
and then we'll fill down to see what
kind of results we get
so this is telling me that number 19 is
the highest i should choose
engineering to be my job
however there's more to the decision
than just adding up
all of these factors this assumes that
every factor is equal
such as the amount of pay you get is
just as likely to influence you as the
job market well in fact job market
might be more important it's nice to
have a high paying job but if you can't
get it
then maybe job factor is a more
important decision than you thought it
was
let's add some new columns in between
each of these categories
we're going to insert a new column so
i'm clicking on the title
the letters at the top the column
headers
and right clicking there and choosing
insert
what i want to do next is add what i
would call an importance factor for each
of these categories for instance
job market i would put that as the
highest of the factors
if i can't find a job then there's no
sense in going into it
employment or enjoyment i should
probably enjoy it i'm going to give it
as a four
my talents so i think i can learn
whatever it is so i'm going to say
that's not as important
schooling it's not important i'm willing
to do as much school as i have to
and then pay i'm going to account that
is a medium factor
now for each of these let's take a
formula to multiply
the relative importance so equals the
relative importance of this
times the factor
for each career now this is going to
require
a absolute reference so where it says
dollar sign c4
i'm going to put a dollar sign in front
of the 4 because i'm going to reference
this number
in the blue every single time after i
fill down
so filling down here shows now the
importance
of the nfl 15
is somewhat moderated now it's got
less of importance than maybe the job
market would have
so let's copy this section here let's
paste it into the next area
and paste it into the next area
and continue on
now let's readjust this when i do the
final tally i just want to say equals
and i'm going to
add up each of these factors
so i'm putting a plus sign between each
cell
and then i will fill down in the last
row
let's give it a title and call it total
so once more 65 shows up as the most
important
of the jobs at least according to my
criteria
a 65.
one more final touch might be to color
code each of these areas so that they
stand out distinctly one from another
now looking at the last the totals let's
do a conditional formatting on these
numbers so
highlighting the numbers i'm going to
choose the top
10 percent that'll show basically the
first
highest ranked item and so 65
65 is the highest number in the list
that shows
which one comes out on top engineering
by the way
is what the computer decision chart
recommends for me
let's see what you have print your work
put your name on it
and you have a decision now of what your
career will be
in this lesson called sales report we're
going to summarize a large amount of
data we're going to have
lots of different sales items we'll
calculate who the best
sales people are in our department and
create this pie chart when we're done
we're going to use some data from some
sales figures to do
database work in microsoft excel
what you see on the screen in front of
you is a report from perhaps the
company's
database on sales for a store
you can see that there's a lot of
columns and a lot of rows so you don't
have to type all these things in
i'll provide you with a spreadsheet so
that you can just manipulate what's
already there
so you can see each title is at the top
and row number one
there's a few blanks that we're going to
use formulas for
and then let's scroll to the bottom and
you will see that has
i think it's 172 boos opens
a sales transaction so
all the way to december here you can see
the sales of each item
in our pool supply store and a little
bit of data about each one
the store cost in column e is how much
the item cost wholesale
sale price is what we sold it for and
then we need to calculate a few items
such as the profit
the commission and then we'll do some
reports on each sales person to find out
who the best
sales person is in our store
well let's do some of the formulas here
that we will have to uh encounter
when we work with sales data over here
in column l i've put some notes on the
formulas that we're going to use and
some of the techniques that you'll see
in this lesson
text to columns which we'll use to split
these names you can see that there's a
first and last name in column i
we want to split them into separate
columns the second function is the
if formula you've seen that before
the next function is called the sumif
which means
you can pick certain areas or certain
items to add together based on a
criteria that you choose
this is a database really more than a
spreadsheet and in databases we do a lot
of sorting
and filtering a new concept that you'll
see is a pivot table
which will give you a summary of like
the number of
sales that each employee makes and then
finally we'll
review charting by making a pie chart
let's start by making the
titles up here in row one more readable
right now they're all compacted together
so let's highlight these
and let's go to text wrapping
text wrapping allows us to see each one
of these in its full text
so now you can see in column b c and h
that there's more text that we didn't
see before
let's start with the item called text to
columns what we would like to do
is to split these columns so that they
have a first name in one column and a
last name in the other
so to do that we're going to need to
insert a new column to give it some
space
so right click on column header j and
choose
insert and so now we have a blank column
to work with
let's go to column i and we're going to
the data tab here
and then choosing text to columns
what this will do it will allow the
computer to parse
the data that's in column i there's two
options
if you used fixed with that means the
first column might have five characters
or seven or whatever you want to choose
but in our case we want to split it
based on the space that's between these
names so
i'm going to choose delimited when you
select delimited it says what are your
delimiters
a delimiter is a divider and so if you
select
any of these items here a tab a
semicolon a comma or space
it will automatically divide the words
on what you choose above
so i'm choosing space and so a space
character between the words
gives us two columns
now let's change these headers now since
they make more sense to say first name
and then last name for each of the sales
people
and so we've added a column now
the next item is to calculate how much
profit was sold
for each of these items for instance
transaction
1001 was a pool cover the product code
is something in our inventory that
we just uh use is based on the maybe the
manufacturer's code
but how much profit do you make if you
sell the item for 98 dollars and it
costs you 58 dollars to buy it from your
supplier
it's a simple formula to say equals this
square here which is
f2 subtract
e2 and press enter and you can see that
we made
forty dollars and ten cents now you
might have to format that using the
key right here under the home button to
get the dollar sign
now how about commission how much money
are we going to give to charlie barnes
for selling this pool cover
well here's the rule above ten percent
commission for items less than fifty
dollars
but if he sells an item that sells for
more than fifty dollars
we'll give him twenty percent of the
profits
so let's go and make a formula using the
if
command equals if my rule says
if this sale price i'll click here
is greater than fifty dollars comma
then let's give him more than
more profit than than less so the rule
says give him 20 percent of the sales
let's make it twenty percent of the
profits actually so let's
take the profit and multiply
that shift in eight and a decimal two so
that's twenty percent
but if it's less than or equal to fifty
comma
then let's take the profits and multiply
by
point one or ten percent
so that's the rule that tells us the
commission
is based on the value of the item that
was sold
press enter so the commission
for this item is 20 percent
it cost more than fifty dollars so we
give him twenty percent of the profits
of the store
so charlie barnes earned eight dollars
and two cents
which is twenty percent of the profit on
this item
now let's just highlight these two
squares
and fill down so i'm going to grab the
little corner and drag
down now it's a little bit hard to fill
down when you have
172 rows so here's another way to fill
down
i'm going to hold the shift key on my
keyboard
after selecting the first two rows
and then slide to the bottom of the
spreadsheet
now i'm going to hold the shift key keep
holding the shift key and click at the
last area
you notice that the whole zone or this
whole region
is selected i'm sliding back to the top
and sliding back to the bottom
now once i have the region selected
where i want to fill these items
i'm going to look for an i a command
called fill down
if i click on home way over on the right
you will see
an item called fill if i click here i
have down right
up and left as my options i want to fill
down i click here
it automatically fills the entire range
so sometimes that's quicker than
trying to fill it down using this little
item in the corner
so i'm going to click to unselect the
range
now you can see in some items such as
this
one gallon of muriatic acid it costs the
company or cost the customer seven
dollars
the profit for the store was three
dollars and doug smith earned
ten percent on that sale so less than
fifty dollar item you get less
commission
scroll back to the top
now the next item that we're going to
look at is called sumif
sumif allows you to add together
a range of items based on a condition
let me show you something more specific
let's go to the bottom
and you can see that i have a few
formulas here
three different sums i want to do the
sum of all items
the sum of all the items that are valued
more than fifty dollars
and the sum of items valued at fifty
dollars or less
so let's go to the cost here
column f which is the profit or that
that is the cost to the customer
the easiest formula is just the sum
formula so i'm going to type
equals sum now what's the range
i'm going to type the range this time
since the cells are so
so many i'm going to type the letter f
and 2
and a colon and then the word letter
f 172 and you can see on the screen
that there's a blue rectangle
surrounding the range
close the item with a parenthesis and
press enter
so in this year the store sales were
seventeen thousand one hundred and ten
dollars
now what my question is is how many of
those items
were valued at fifty dollars or more
what is the sum of all those items
the new formula that we use now is
called sumif so
type equals sum if and now let's take a
look at what i can put in here
it's called a range and a criteria
so this the range is once again f2
colon f172 that gives me this
the range of all the sales and the price
to the customer
now a comma the criteria
i'm going to have to put a quotation
mark
and then a greater than 50 and another
quotation mark
what that will do is it will sum only
the items
that are greater than 50. so press enter
you can see that sixteen thousand eighty
eight dollars is the sum of all items
that were costing more than fifty
dollars
well let's use the same formula but this
time let's
choose any items that are valued at
fifty or less
so that is equals sum if
the range will be the same f2 colon
f172 and a comma
now this time i'm going to put in my
rule as
less than or equal to 50
and a quotation and a parenthesis
so now i can see that the vast majority
of my sales
are for items that are 50 or more
hopefully these two items these two
cells
add up to the entire sum
okay let's scroll back to the top and
see what other items we have to do
two items that you do in most database
work is with sorting
and filtering so let's go see how that
works
go to the data tab and right here you
see sort
and filter sorting in filter
is exactly how you would think it would
work let's choose sorting first
what do we want to sort by we can sort
by
the first or
we can sort by the last name of an
employee
and click ok and so now all the items
have been rearranged so that
the last name is alphabetized so all the
barnes items come up first and then
hernandez starts at row number 35
so we've sorted by column j basically
you can resort again and this time
choose a different item let's go back to
sorting by
the sale location
so if you're looking for all the items
that are alphabetized according to
column k
you sort by sale location
and so all the arizona sales are first
and the letter c comes next new mexico
and then finally the last items that
show up on the list
are utah so sorting
let's sort one more time i want to sort
back to the transaction number which was
the original
way that the spreadsheet was sorted
so the last item and the first item now
are back in order
the next item is filtering if you want
to filter some items to show only
certain
values you use the next button filter
what are we going to filter
as soon as you click that button all
these titles automatically
have a little arrow next to them so what
happens if i choose one of them such as
sales location
i can unclick certain items if i only
want to show
one state such as new mexico i leave a
check mark there
and click ok and so now it looks like my
spreadsheet is much shorter
it's only one screen full all the items
have this in common they have
nm in this column k
however don't be fooled the other items
are still there they're just hidden
look at the row numbers we start with
two jump to eight
nine thirteen eighteen so there's lots
of rows that are hidden
just because we sorted or we filtered
by the sales location let's go back and
select all of them
click ok try filtering by other columns
let's filter by
let's say by the first name let's see i
only want to see
helen i'm looking at her sales
and now i see just helen's results
yeah remember the other items are still
there we just want to hide them
temporarily so that's filtering
sorting and filtering are useful when
you're doing analysis on a bunch of data
like you have here
the next item that i would like to use
is called the pivot tables
pivot table is a way to summarize a
large group of data
so i'm going to select just the data
that i'm going to work with here i'm
going to select from cell a
and highlight all the way down to the
other corner of my spreadsheet so i'm
holding my mouse button down
moving all the way to the bottom to row
number 172.
it's important that i limit my my pivot
table to only this data i don't want to
include the summary at the bottom
nor do i want to include anything that's
over on the right in column
m so after i have selected
all items i go to the insert tab
and i'm choosing a pivot table
pivot tables show up next says what
columns are we going to use you can see
the selection here is from a1 to
k172 that's what i've just selected
it's going to create a new worksheet up
until now we've only used one worksheet
it's always been called sheet one as you
can see at the bottom
but when i click ok you will see now i
have a new sheet
this one says sheet3 yours probably says
sheet2
now what are we going to put in a pivot
table first of all in a pivot table you
think of what you're going to
add together or make a summary of
well all i care about now is the sales
figures for each of my
sales people so i'm going to select last
name
and the sale price of each item
you notice that we have a little summary
here
barnes sold six thousand dollars
when i clicked those the computer
guessed what i wanted to do
it says i'm going to use the rows of the
last name
and choose the sum of the sales item
there are other ways you can add these
together you can count them you can
average them
put the maximum most often you use some
you can experiment with other items you
can drag these around and get strange
results
you can do filtering there's a lot to do
with pivot tables but for all
our purposes today is i want to leave
this as
the sum of the values and the row labels
as the last name of each employee
let's format these as dollars figures
because that's what they are
and now you can see that the best sales
person in my store
is barnes smith comes in a close second
hernandez needs some help to show this
visually
we can highlight these numbers and
create a chart
let's go to insur insert and a pie chart
would be an appropriate
type of sales figure here so i like
three dimensional pie charts
let's put this next to the other and you
can see
the last name of each sales person and
the percentages
of the total sales
you might want to show some data on this
graph as well
you can right click this and you can
choose
add data labels so you can click here
and it will show the actual number of
sales that each employee earned
adjust the colors and the formatting to
your style
now the last thing we should do is print
a worksheet so let's put your name up
here
and then print this page when you go to
print
make sure that it fits on one sheet so i
choose print
you can see in the preview that i have
two pieces of paper here
it's not really necessary to have two
let's make this
a horizontal landscape
and let's condense this
to one page
and click print in this lesson called
car database we're trying to get some
more advanced features of excel
you can see that we have literally a
database of
lots of cars we're going to find out how
many miles they each worked
we're going to do some formulas with
text to so we can combine
fields together and split them apart and
we're going to do some averages
and create some charts as well so let's
get started with a car database
welcome to excel assignment number seven
this is a database
of all the company cars that you own in
your business
this is a rather extensive spreadsheet
so we're going to split the lesson into
three parts
you can see the lesson contents on the
screen first of all we're going to use
importing to create a text file into a
spreadsheet
the second is we'll introduce three new
formulas left middle and right
we'll use vlookup formulas to create a
value out of a table
we'll review the if formula we use the
concatenate formula to put cells
together
we'll work on a pivot table and lastly
we'll import
our documents into microsoft word
your company fleet manager might have a
computer system that does tracking
and he's asking you to do some analysis
now on the cars that are in your company
usually when a person gives you a
database
you have a few options you can modify it
in a database program such as
access or perhaps what you're more
familiar with
is with excel and so we're going to use
a database
aspect of how excel works today you'll
see that they have a the spreadsheet on
the screen
shows the cars that we own in the
company with some ids some miles their
cars and years and their makes their
numbers the principal driver
and so we're going to do several steps
with database functions
using excel first of all you won't get a
spreadsheet
when you ask for inventories usually
what you get is a text file and so what
i have on the desktop here is a
spreadsheet
in the form of a text file if i double
click this
it looks ugly you see that it is not in
a spreadsheet format
at least not yet this is what you
get from reports from sales data
from your amazon account or your
insurance company or your
bank these formats are called text
formats they don't have any they don't
have any spreadsheet
graphs they don't have any colors it's
just straight text
but excel knows how to work with these
very well you notice all these commas
here
these are all separators they show the
different columns that will come
in the spreadsheet so i'll show you how
to work with this now
i'm going to close this first and start
excel
now instead of starting by working with
the file itself we have to import it so
i'm going to the word file
and i'm going to open a document and i'm
going to choose
this text file i would go find it first
so i click on computer
and let's browse and
let's navigate to the desktop that's
where i have this file saved
and it doesn't show up why not
well remember the extension on a text
file is txt
and excel is just looking for
spreadsheets right now so i'm going to
change the filter here
to show all files on the desktop and
then scroll through it again
and there it is there's the car
inventory txt
now when i open it it's going to ask me
some questions
how do i handle this what do i do
are these like text files that are
equal sized cells each or they delimited
well these are all separated by commas
as you can see in the preview
and so we're going to stick with the
delimited idea
choose next and how are they delimited
is the next question
are they separated by tabs semicolons
commas spaces or
something else well these are all
separated by commas
and as soon as i click comma you notice
all these columns seem to line up
as they are intended and so that looks
like i'm on the right track i'll click
finish
and so now i have the start of my
spreadsheet each comma
creates a separate column in the
spreadsheet
let's take you through some steps here
you're going to have to follow this
pretty closely there's no
room for creativity on this assignment
just follow exactly
how it's presented here first of all
let's change the columns
so that the column headers so that they
can show the entire
title so we'll use text wrapping the
first thing i would like to do is
introduce some new formulas that are
able to handle
text you can take pieces of a field
and create new fields for instance
whoever invented this car
id for the company was trying to squeeze
as much information
into the id as possible and so we used a
code like
fd for ford zero six for the year
mtg for mustang
and zero zero one is the car number
that's not normally recommended to try
to squeeze data into a field like this
but that's what he's doing
so we need to come up with a few ideas
on how to separate
these fields let's go to where it says
make
i want to take the first two letters off
of each of these
data items so the first two letters
is going to be using a formula called
left
and if i cho if i choose that you notice
the options are
first of all choose text well i'm going
to choose this is my text
and the next after this comma is the
number of letters
well in my database it looks like the
first two letters
are the manufacturer's names so let's
use a closed parenthesis and sure enough
you can see that it's just slicing off
the first two letters
of the database well let's fill this
down
and see what we have here
all the way to the bottom how many are
there looks like 53.
and so you can see we have two letters
for each
of the make now what do those mean let's
let's ca let's create a new formula
and we're going to put in column c the
manufacturer's name i'd like to put in
just the word ford
or down here general motors t y must
stand for toyota
ho is honda cr is
chrysler and hy is hyundai we're going
to introduce a new function here called
a lookup table let's take these items
here like
cr and hy and ty and ho
and gm and fd these are all our
manufacturers
and let's actually put the real name
here
okay you can see that i've created a
small table that coordinates these
abbreviations with the full name
to make this work though i have to have
these in alphabetical order
so i'm going to highlight these just
these cells not the whole table
and sort them so i look for the data
command
and sort it says what do you want to
sort by i want to sort by the first
column
and click ok if you don't put them in
alphabetical order
this next process is not going to work
now that i've got these charts here i'm
going to
look them up i'm going to look up
fd in the chart and put in the word ford
the computer function to do that is
called equals v
lookup that means vertical lookup it's
going to look through a table
vertically look up the words fd or the
letters fd
and then return the second column which
is
forward so let's type in the whole
command here lookup
and let's follow all these options
through first of all
the first item it's looking for is the
lookup value
so fd is the lookup value
put a comma and then the next item says
table
array the table is the little set of
data at the bottom
i'm going to scroll down this table
and then a comma then it says
column index number
that means which column in this table
contains the real word that you're
looking for not the abbreviation but the
real word so the second column
contains chrysler 4 general motors so
i'm going to type a 2 up here
and a comma and then actually this is
the the only option that we need
we can close the parenthesis now press
enter and scroll to the top
notice it says forward looks like it's
working
be careful there's still one error with
this but we'll discover that in a moment
if i fill this down you're going to
notice there's a relative reference
error problem
everything stops working after the third
row
it has this n a which means not
available or not accessible
and so what's going on well if i double
click on the second
item and you'll see that this table
is looking at rows 57 through 62.
and you notice down here that it's been
shifted down one
that should send an alert to your mind
to say oh the computer is using
relative references instead of absolute
references
so if i go back to ford and double click
this
i'm going to modify this so i'm going to
put in a dollar sign
in front of 56 and a dollar sign in
front of 61
so that means that it's always going to
use those row numbers
every time i look up a value and now it
looks like it's creating the
the results i want so let's go all the
way to the bottom
and you see that we've created a new
field in our database
that shows the manufacturer's name
now the model is the second item well
the model
is found here this is the the letters
mtg
so we can't just use the left command
like we did
for the manufacturer so we're going to
use a new item called
mid command so in this case we have an
a ford mustang mtg stands for mustang
so let's uh let's pull out some letters
well
to pull out the manufacturers make we
use the first two letters
and so we use the left command well we
want to pull something out of the middle
of the text so this one is called the
mid command mid it says here that it's
going to return the characters
from the middle of a text string given
the starting position and the length
so let's put a parenthesis the first
item that it's looking for is the text
so we'll click here
and then a comma the start number where
does this
m start that's at position one two three
four
five so it starts at position five in
the string
and then a comma how many characters do
we need
well these all have three characters in
each of the model
numbers okay close parenthesis and enter
and now we see mtg so let's fill these
down a ways and you can see that it's
pulling out
other items fcs that must stand for ford
focus
and then a general motors
cmr an slv
let's see what some of these others are
scrolling all the way to the bottom and
filling down
you can see that we have some of these
others now the meaning of all these
models can be interpreted as follows
mtg is for mustang fsc is for focus
cmr is a camaro slv is a silverado
toyota camry and a toyota corolla are
next
and let's see a civic looks like a honda
civic
a honda odyssey and what's next here
a pt cruiser a chrysler caravan
and then the honda elantra so these are
all different models
so at the bottom here we're going to do
the exact same process
of creating a lookup table so i'm going
to copy down
all of these manufacturer model names
and then put the real name next to them
okay i'm finished with typing in all of
these car models
and their full name remember
a vlookup table only works if it's
alphabetized so i'm going to highlight
these
squares choose sort
and sort by the first column which is d
click ok and so now the this line is in
alphabetical order
once we have that done we can create a
lookup value
so i'm going to use the exact same
lookup as my model
i'm going to copy this and paste it over
here
it doesn't seem to be working right it
says elantra is the first item
what's going on i'll double click here
to find out
we're looking for d56 through e61
well that's almost there the only
problem is
this table is longer so i'm going to
extend this one all the way to the
bottom
and press enter and go back to the top
now it looks like it's finding mustang
correctly
since the other one was created with the
absolute references we have the dollar
signs in the
in the top it seems to be working right
so we'll fill down
and we'll have the model name for each
of these cars
almost there let's open this a little
lighter
we have an error down here what's going
on
this one says not accessible or not
available
what's wrong with this we have a zero od
somebody in their stupidity typed in a
zero
instead of an o back at the beginning
here
so let's fix that up here at the top we
have
the ho and then the year
we have an extra zero in there so let's
delete that zero
and press enter and now it appears that
that typo is fixed
so when you get text from another
company sometimes you have to realize
that
people didn't enter the data correctly
lastly let's put in the manufacturer
year
this is going to use the mid command
again
we're going to pull out the year from
this square
put a comma it's going to start at
position 3
and we're going to take two text items
two letters
and we get zero six that one seems a
little simpler
so we'll scroll that down and now we'll
pull out just the year
a two digit year for each of these cars
now we need a formula to calculate the
age
how old is our car
well let's put in an equal sign
what would you do given
that i'm creating this spreadsheet in
the year 2014
i'm just going to take 14 and subtract
the years that come before
and press enter and it says 8
so a 2006 car is eight years old
seems to work let's see what happens
when i fill down
most of the time it works except for
here what's this it says there's a
problem with it
now if you look closely at this this is
an o6
it's literally an o6 we want zero
six so once more somebody thought that
it was an o6
and in the database they put a oh the
letter o
in here so let's delete that o
and put in a zero and so that fixes that
value
the same happened here let's go back to
this row 15.
i'm deleting the o and i'm re-typing a
zero
let's continue to fill down and see what
other errors might show up
oops there's another one another value
that says it cannot be read
so let's go to here
h o and then a zero five
so we've had to do some corrections to
our data
now this formula is very simple it's
actually too simple
this car is negative 84 years old
where did that come from well that was
called the y2k bug
where computers just held two digits for
every year it worked until we switched
over to the year 2000
so a 98 is actually
16 years old and it gives us a negative
84.
that's because it's taking the formula
minus the value in cell b1
f19 well it's a correct number according
to the computer but it doesn't serve our
purposes
we want to make sure that the number
comes out correctly so let's readjust
our formula
let's erase this one and i'm going to
ask a question
if if
the difference between 14
minus this gets less than zero
then i want a formula for all those 90s
and 80s cars
well i just simply say i'll take 100
minus the year and that'll get us the
distance between 98 to 200 2000 that
would be about two
and then i'm going to add 14 to get to
our current value
otherwise we'll just use the previous
formula we'll say 14
minus this here and so now we have two
different cases
for those that are less than two
thousand and those that are greater than
two thousand
if i press enter i still get the same
results for the firsts
and let's scroll to the bottom and see
what happens
and so sometimes a simple calculation
needs to
have a few cases so yeah this is correct
now
a 1999 car in the year 2014
is 15 years old so the formula seems to
work
now let's go over to this formula miles
per year
well that should be pretty simple at
least at first glance
we want to say this equals the total
miles
divided by the years driven which is the
age of the car
and so that shows 50 5000 miles
let's fill this down and let's see if it
works
almost all of them work there's a few
errors
there's an error it says divide by zero
why in the world are we getting that
error
that's because over here in the age it
says this car is zero years old
it was made in 2014. is it really zero
years old
well it's less than a year old but it's
not zero
so it's probably six months old maybe
three months old
let's make a slight adjustment to our
formula
if i double click on this formula you'll
see that i'm dividing
eight the age divided by
the miles well the age in some of these
was
zero we can't really divide by zero
and this car really is not exactly eight
years old it might be eight years
and six months because a car that is
zero years old really
has a few months already on it so let's
just round a little bit let's
let's add a little bit of a number
well let's see we want to add something
to g2 so i'm going to have to put a
parenthesis before g2
and add 0.5 so let's add
let's add a decimal point five so that
that
year is really a year and six months
why parentheses well you should know
from your order of operations in your
algebra class
that you're supposed to add and subtract
after you divide and multiply
and so we want to make sure that we add
first
and then divide so that's why the
parentheses are there
if i press enter and then fill this
formula down
we should get better results so the
mileage calculation is based on
the age plus six months and we have no
divide by zero
errors let's format these two columns
they could probably use some commas to
make them look more like
miles it's easier to see when you have
thousands if you have a comma in there
let's move let's keep moving the color
of this is black
white green etc that's fine we'll use
that in a few minutes when we get to the
new car id
the principal driver shows the last name
of each employee
how many warranty miles are there on
this car
this is a fifty thousand mile warranty
and this car is just barely under the
warranty it still has ten thousand to go
well the question is is this covered
under warranty that's the formula we're
going to do next
and so we'll do an if calculation if
if the miles are less than or equal to
the warranty and yes it is covered and
so i'm just going to put the letter y
for covered
a comma so if it's not covered i'm going
to write the word not
covered and then a quotation
and a parenthesis so now
this says yes it is covered i get a y
if i fill down i will see a different
value for each of these cars
and some are covered and some are not
covered under the warranty
the last item that we're going to fill
in here is called the new car
id your boss gives you this requirement
he says take the original id and i want
you to squeeze in
three more letters in between the
manufacturer
and this last three digit number and i
want to
i want to know what color is the car
so once more this is a bad idea to try
to squeeze as much information into one
field
but your boss said so so it's the truth
let's do it
how do we con how do we how do we
combine
fields the formula they're looking for
is called
concatenate c-o-n and then you'll see
concatenate shows up here if i click it
double click it the format that you're
supposed to
to fill in is simply says text 1 text 2
etc
so we're going to concatenate a bunch of
fields
we want to put first of all continue
using fd
comma and then we want to have the
manufacturer's year
that comes as you can see that comes
second in the list
and then we want to continue on with the
model
and then a comma and now your boss said
put in
the color so we want to put in black
we're going to adjust that because he
only wants the first three letters
of the word so we're going to delete
this
two squares i want to know just the left
three letters of black so i have
the left three of j2
so j2 comma three and a closed
parenthesis and a comma so
we've just added the left three letters
of black
and now what we need is the last
three from here
so we use the formula right
click here comma three
double close parenthesis and press enter
so now we have the new car id
one more change that we need to make is
that
this shows lower case letters
your boss didn't tell you but he forgot
to say
all ids in cars have upper case letters
only
well there's a nice formula to put in
there if i want to
isolate these
letters and change them to uppercase
the formula they're looking for is
called upper
so i put a parenthesis around the part
that i want to be
uppercase and press enter and now
the new car id shows bla
as black
i'm filling down and now we have a new
car id
okay so those are a lot of different
database functions that you can use to
manipulate text
the next item in our checklist of things
that we're going to see on this
assignment
is called a pivot table a pivot table
allows you to summarize data for
instance
your boss might ask of these drivers
who has the greatest amount of miles
there's some formulas you could work
with but here is one of them
it's called a pivot table i'm going to
insert
and under the insert command you see
pivot table
it says what's my range that i'm going
to work with and it automatically
selects the entire spreadsheet
click ok a pivot table creates a new
sheet
down here you notice this one said car
inventory and this sheet is called
sheet1
i'm going to select the driver first
put a check mark next to him and then i
want to know about the miles on the car
so i click on
miles automatically the computer assumes
that i want the sum of the miles
and the driver and so now we have a
chart that shows
each driver and the number of miles that
he created
well you could also put in a chart
and create a list of all the drivers
and their miles and so smith jumps out
right away from our graph
whoever smith is he's driving a lot
let's go back to our car inventory and
see what smith is up to
smith what kind of car does he have well
he has a ford mustang no wonder he's
driving so much
i would drive a lot too if somebody gave
me a mustang and so smith
shows his miles as the most of
anyone in the series another type of
graph that we haven't worked with yet is
called a scatter chart
a scatter chart allows you to put a
specific data points
on a graph so i'm going to select here
the age of the car and the miles
just these two columns i'll click on
their column headers
and select the entire column i'm going
to insert a new chart
and the chart that i'm looking for here
has a bunch of points on it it's called
a scatter chart
and as soon as you select it you can see
what it's doing it's pointing each of
these graphs each one of these dots on
the graph shows
that the years across the bottom
are showing from zero years up to looks
like about 18 is the oldest car
and then the number of miles each car
has
and so it almost looks like a straight
line well
there is something called a trend line
that we're looking for so i'm clicking
on the plus sign up here
and i'm selecting trend line and now
there's a dotted line
that goes up and down through the middle
of these dots
we could probably make these axis titles
a little bit easier to read so
i'm going to select those as well
deleting the word axis title and putting
in the word miles
miles driven
and then down here on this axis i'm
changing this to the age of the car
age of the car and then in parentheses
years
and so let's park this off to the side
and slide over so now we have a chart
that shows the miles
in our inventory some of these are
outliers
some of these are right on the line
one more way that we could do some
analysis is we could find out which
cars are being driven more than others
so let's select column i
let's go to conditional formatting
let's try out something called the color
scales let's pick one of these color
scales there's blue and green and red
it doesn't matter which one you choose
but when you pick one you'll see that
some colors are
highlighted in darker and lighter colors
these show you the extremes
so like this 35 000 shows up
as one of the highest let's sort this
spreadsheet
based on the miles driven per year
the first thing we have to do is select
just the range
where our data is stored we're going to
ignore these
lookup tables at the bottom so i'm
highlighting all the way
down to row 53
and then going to the data tab and
choosing sort
let's sort by column
what column is this column i
and let's go from the largest to the
smallest and click ok
and so you can see that this car here
this particular car
has 35 000 miles per year on
average it only has six months and the
guy is already driven at 17 000 miles
if we scroll to the bottom you'll see
that the minimum
driven car is this ford mustang here
it's eight years old and it has forty
thousand miles on it
the last item i'd like to do is to
create a report
so let's go back to microsoft word
and we're going to copy and paste a few
of these items from our spreadsheet
the title of our report is going to have
our name on it
next i'm simply going to put the top
drivers by miles
and then i'm going to go back to excel
go back to my sheet
copy this graph so i'm going to right
click it
choose copy and you can see you can go
back to word
right click it and choose pastes
and so these two programs integrate with
each other
press enter a couple times and i'm going
to show the next is the scatter chart
for the car inventory so it says the
scatter chart for the car
inventory miles on each car now i'm
going back to excel
and i'm going to copy this graph here
that has the scatter chart so right
click on it
choose copy go back to word
right click and choose paste
and so i have two charts that came from
my graph let's print these
and call that our final assignment one
more thing when you go to save a
document
in excel that was created using a text
file
you can see up here it says car
inventory text
when you go to save that you're going to
get an error message
it says you're still in the tab
formatted
text do you want to keep using that
format
you should say no we want to save this
using
a new format instead of tab
delimited or text delimited we're just
going to choose excel workbook
and now all those pretty blue
and all the formula and all the other
things that were created in the charts
they will stay with your spreadsheet a
regular tab or text delimited
file cannot possibly save these items
okay in microsoft word let's go file and
print
and we'll call our document done in this
section we're going to talk about
problem solving
and so you can see that susan in front
of us has a problem
she wants to take a vacation and wants
to spend as little amount as possible
and so our options are to go on a
caribbean cruise go to orlando
or go to chicago each one of these
requires flights car rentals and hotels
admission fees
and so excel is a great tool to figure
out which one of these would be the
least expensive
and so i will give you a partial
solution
but that by this point in the course
though you're supposed to be able to
solve some of these problems on your own
and so it will
stretch your thinking and reinforce the
skills that you've learned before
so problem solving is going to start
with a simple problem
and then gradually i'll give you several
until you get to the most complex
problem
when you reach the end you will be
considered a person that can use excel
to solve real problems in your personal
life and
in your job as well hi in this video i'm
going to show you how to calculate
interest on a simple interest payment
plan
for four loans with different interest
rates and then make a graph
so here's the final product that we're
going to arrive at at the end of this
video and so you'll see that we have a
ten thousand dollar loan with four
different interest rates
and then we have monthly payments at the
right column
let's start up a new spreadsheet and
then we're going to put in the data
labels
so the first thing i'm going to do is
fill out the column titles for
our loan so the first column is
principal the interest rate
the months that we have to pay over the
total interest paid
the number of dollars that the total
loan will be and then the monthly
payments
in the first column let's put in labels
here for loan a b
c and d i'd like to make sure that these
column headers are correct so let's
double click on the little line that's
between each of these dividers
and that will separate the column to be
exactly the right width for the label
so let's zoom in and let's check out
what our payments will be
so let's make up a principal number for
our loan let's say we're buying a car
and i'm going to spend ten thousand
dollars that i don't have
so i enter in 10 000 and you can see
that the numbers don't quite fit now so
let's
expand the column a little bit and if
you don't have dollar signs you can go
up to the accounting area and you can
change this to a dollar sign if you want
now the interest rate if i put in a
number here let's say
nine percent and i use the percent sign
it will calculate the number correctly
however if you don't put in the nine
percent you can put in 0.09 which is the
decimal equivalent of nine percent
and then if you choose the percent sign
it will show it correctly
now the number of months let's say i
have a 12 month loan and so i put in a
12.
so these three columns here are going to
be numbers that we enter
and then the last three columns are
going to be the formulas that help us
solve our problem
so let's start with the formula interest
pay so that's a formula where we type in
equals
we want to take the principal which is
b2
and i will multiply by c2 which is the
rate
so you can either type in equals b2 and
use the star key which is the shift
8 and that's for multiply and then
finally type in z2
c2 and press enter and that will tell us
that the total amount of
interest is nine hundred dollars over
the price of the loan
so then the next column is the number of
dollars paid total
so we have to pay back our money let's
go with equals
and we'll click the ten thousand then we
put in a plus
sign because we have to add the number
of dollars interests
that we're going to pay as well and so
that's 900
and press enter so the total cost of
your car will be
10 900 now you're going to pay this
over the life of the loan so we're going
to take this
total amount and divide it by 12. so
we'll take divide by
the number of months that we just agreed
to pay so that's
f2 divided by e2 and press enter
so your monthly payment for this car is
908 dollars
now you can adjust this quite easily if
you want to change something so let's
click in here and let's say i have a 20
000 loan from my car and you can see the
payment automatically is recalculated
now you're shopping between different
banks and you want to see what the
competitive rates are
so let's take our 20 000 and i'm going
to select
and fill down so let's see i'm selecting
this whole
bracket of looks like 12 different cells
i'm using the control key and d on the
keyboard
and that is for fill down now i want to
calculate on different rates
so one bank here decided to give me an
eight percent loan
another one is seven and even six
percent so i shopped around and i found
four different rates
now the number of dollars that i pay is
equal and the number of months that i
pay is equal
now let's take the last three columns
and we're going to
fill down so i'm going to select those
three columns
and drag from the small dot in the
corner
and this will calculate my interest
based on
the 12-month payment so let's see here
the interest rate is better for the six
percent
and then the total monthly payment is
slightly lower
now i'd like to visually present this so
let's select the
total monthly payment and we'll make a
bar chart out of it
so let's see let's go to the insert tab
here and i'm going to select a chart for
bar chart
let's choose this first one
now there's my chart and let's see i'll
zoom out slightly
let's put in a chart title and i'm going
to call this monthly payments for ten
thousand dollars
all right now at the bottom you can see
that i have this one two
three four i would like to compare the
interest rates that's the only thing
that changes in here is the 9876
so let's do a right click on the chart
here and choose select data
in the column here where it says axis
labels i'm going to edit this
and it says please give me a range so i
can just simply select from the chart
here's 8
7 6 7 8 9 and then it puts in the
correct columns there c2 to c5
and that is exactly what i'm looking for
click ok
and then it says here this is what i'm
going to display now which is 9876
and click ok and there you got your
chart
my name is chad sluter and my youtube
channel is called tech made simple
i'm a university professor that teaches
programming uh computer software
development and
security all kinds of technology
including
what you just saw here with microsoft
excel
welcome to excel problem solvers this is
a set of examples of how you can use
excel
in solving real world problems problems
that are too
complex to solve with a regular
calculator or
to solve in your head so we're going to
look at susan and tim
every time we get a new page in this
booklet we're going to see
that they have a different task and so
here's what we're going to do for each
page
first of all we'll listen to tim and
susan and tell us about their problem
we'll build a spreadsheet with proper
formulas now i'm going to show you
a partial solution for each of these
solutions we're going to create a
spreadsheet
with a little bit of a design but i'm
going to assume that you've already done
some excel work and so that you can
finish this
with a little bit of collaboration with
your friends and a little bit of thought
and then finally every one of these
solutions will have a graph it'll be a
bar
chart that will show a comparison so
let's see what these different problems
are
the first problem we're going to look at
is a school shopping list
and so susan has a lot of things to buy
and she has three different stores to
shop at
tim also has a shopping list that's
slightly different
the second problem we'll face is should
we buy a cat or dog
and so we'll look at all the different
costs associated with buying each of
those
the next problem that susan faces that
she wants to take a vacation
and so we're going to give three
different options either
a caribbean cruise orlando or chicago
tim's going to do the same vacation but
he has a different number of people
the next problem is that they're going
to purchase printers and so there's
three different kinds of printers to
choose from and the cost of ink for each
is different number five is more
complicated yet we're going to
untangle the cell phone bill number six
is we're going to choose from three
different cars
a very economical car and a luxury
in this first excel problem we're going
to go on a shopping trip
and so we have a shopping list susan
says
i'm susan would you help me pick one of
these three stores to buy my school
supplies
here's my shopping list and so to the
right of the shopping list you can see
all the items
that susan would like to buy her choices
are waltmart
dollar trap and office repo
each price is listed below and then
her number of items that she would like
to buy are listed on her shopping list
so for instance three ballpoint pens
at walmart it's going to cost her three
times 50 cents
or a dollar fifty now this is a large
complicated shopping list
with many items so this is a perfect way
to solve a problem using an excel
spreadsheet
inside the excel spreadsheet that we're
going to create we need to
add a list of all of the items in the
shopping list
and then a column for each store and so
pause the video right now and type these
in
just as you see on the screen
next let's go back to the shopping list
each price
listed at each store has to be put into
the spreadsheet
and then put them into this column under
walmart
pause this video until you have the
numbers typed in
now you might say these look like
dollars so let's make a dollar sign
each of them let's open the currency add
a dollars
let's add the prices for dollar trap and
also for office repo
so pause the video until you have all
the prices listed for each of the stores
now i'm going to help you a little bit
further with the problem
but not completely let's start by
looking at susan's shopping list
for each item for the ballpoint pen we
know how many she needs
such as three and so i copy down the
number of items that she needs
now how would you figure out the amount
of money that she would spend on
ballpoint pens
let's put that formula right here
you know that she's going to spend 1.50
if she shops at walmart
3 times 50. here are some hints for the
formula
in this square which is g3 we're going
to
multiply the quantity times the price
so enter your formula once you figure
that out
after you figure out the first formula
you'll be able to fill down
and calculate all the rest of the prices
as well
at the very end let's put in the total
and so you'll know what the cost is for
purchasing supplies
at walmart repeat the same process for
another column
we're going to figure out the price for
the entire shop list the dollar trap
and then we'll figure out the price
again at austral
once you finish you should have three
total prices listed down here after you
add up all of these numbers
close the last thing you'll need to do
is put a chart on the graph
and so copy the labels from row 2 down
to the bottom
and when you find the totals like i've
mentioned here
you can highlight the entire two rows
create your chart and it will be labeled
correctly
now for the other fellow we're going to
have to make another chart so copy
everything you get from susan
and then you could probably move it over
to column k
or so and paste all of the information
just change the shopping list so that
tim's list will be
shown instead of susan's then you'll be
finished good luck
in this video in excel problem solvers
we're going to look at a problem that
susan and tim
are facing they want to purchase
a dog or a cat and so let's see what
susan says
she says i'm susan would you help me
choose a pet
i love both cats and dogs equally but i
would like to spend as little money as
possible each year
compare these expenses in a spreadsheet
and show me your answer
create a graph first of all notice that
she's talking about
a year and so at the bottom down here
when
it says hints it says use a spreadsheet
to calculate the total cost of ownership
for owning a pet for one year
so we'll just assume one year is the
length of our expenses
pets adoptions dogs are 50
cats are 90. all expenses
include all of the vaccinations spaying
and neutering
however there are more expenses than
just buying the cat or the dog
first of all this is a list of what we
consider necessary accessories
the cat has three items the dog is four
so you have to buy this one time
the second box shows the ongoing
expenses
a box of cat food kitty litter
and the small prince says buy two of
each of these
for my pet each month and so will double
that expense
each month the dog has some expenses too
his dog food is more money and his dog
treats are also an expense
here's a good pattern for setting up the
spreadsheet you can see that i have
two boxes and i colored these boxes so
that way you can distinguish that
there's a section called
initial costs so these are just one time
costs
and these are monthly costs then we have
a column for the dog
and a column for the cat when we're done
we're going to have
a total of how much it costs to keep the
dog for the first year so we'll be
adding up all the numbers above it
what are the initial costs well the
purchase price for the dog
we have to buy a collar a tag a bowl a
leash
and then the initial total will be the
sum of everything above it
the cat will have some of these expenses
i think the cat
will have a zero here because it doesn't
need a leash
for the monthly expenses remember
there's going to be
food litter and treats so
these will be subtotaled and then we're
going to multiply by two because we need
to have a monthly total
each one of those items was bought twice
a month
for the one year costs we're going to
have to take 12 times the monthly total
and then add it to the initial so think
through how each of these costs need to
be added in
to get an accurate price for a dog and
an accurate price for a cat
when we're done we will highlight these
two lines
create a chart and so you'll have a bar
chart that shows
the cost of a dog compared to the cost
of a cat
so there's a good outline for you
remember this is just a partial solution
that i'm offering you
you have to come up with the formulas
and use the numbers to get an accurate
result
welcome to the next lesson of excel
problem solvers this is number three
where we're going to take susan and
tim and ask them what they want to buy
we'll evaluate this with a spreadsheet
and then hopefully come up with a graph
so susan
and tim are both going on vacation and
they're going to explore
either a caribbean cruise orlando
or chicago first of all she says i'm
susan
would you help me pick one of these
three vacations my husband and i
like all three vacation ideas but we
want to spend as little as possible
we will fly stay five nights
and four days tell me which one of these
will cost the least
and so we're going to build a
spreadsheet to answer that question
which one of these will cost the least
let's look at the details of what kind
of vacations they are
the caribbean cruise is the simplest
it's 555
with almost everything included the only
thing it does not include it says here
is
airfare so we have to buy plane tickets
to get to miami
orlando has theme parks
and so they're going to spend four days
and look at each theme park
so for her it's going to cost twice the
price of each ticket
they're not going to rent a car it says
in the small print they will spend money
on a hotel
and they estimate 50 per person on food
each day
lastly we have chicago chicago is a
city of museums and so they're going to
go visit the natural history the museum
of art the science museum and the
broadcast history museum
and so each of these prices is per
person
in chicago they have to rent a car their
hotel is a little bit more money
and they estimate about 50 per day for
food
and this box over here we show the costs
of the airline
so miami orlando and chicago are all
different costs and those are per person
now let's look at how we would build a
spreadsheet
first of all we have a column for each
city
so we have chicago orlando and miami
at the bottom of the page we're
eventually going to have a total
for all of these cities so we'll find
out the answer down here and then we'll
make a graph
i've divided the costs up into per
person expenses
so if you have more people in your
family per person expenses will go up
and then hotel expenses assuming that
all people stay in the same room
it will cost the same for two people as
it will for four
and so the hotel is more of a fixed cost
per night rather than per person
now for some of these we won't have a
number for instance
if we look at chicago we will have
no money for disneyland so we can just
put a zero in there
also for like the museum the science
museum
we will not have a science museum cost
in orlando some of these costs will be
just
zero it appears that there's something
missing
i have hotels and tickets but there is
also car rentals so you might want to
include another car rental expense
somewhere down at the bottom and add
that into the subtotal
so calculate all of the subtotals per
person expenses
hotel expenses car expenses add them
together
compare the three cities and give susan
her answer with a bar graph
once you've finished with susan then you
can use her work to copy and paste a new
chart
a new bar graph and you'll have tim's
answers as well
remember he has two children so his per
person expenses will be higher
good luck in helping tim and susan pick
their vacation
welcome to excel problem solvers so
susan and tim
both would like to buy a printer susan
says would you help me pick one of these
three printers
i plan to print about 15 pages each day
so the five days per week i want the
total cost to be as low as possible
i expect the printer to last two years
you'll see that the epsilon printer is
only 29 dollars
and so you might think that is the best
price at the beginning
until you look at the supplies and
you'll see that ink
is forty dollars a cartridge and it uh
will add up quite a bit
tim on the other hand has a different
request he said i'm tim would you help
me pick one of these three printers
i plan to print about 500 pages each day
and so his printer will probably be
different
than susan's let's look at the fine
print
first of all you'll notice that each
cartridge on the epsilon will only print
200 sheets
while at the other end the xero printer
will print 11 000 pages for a cartridge
and so the initial price on the printer
even though it's high
may end up being less expensive per page
here's a suggestion for how to set up
your spreadsheet
we'll do columns b c and d for each of
the printers
we'll put in a line for their initial
purchase price
and then we'll put the yellow section
for the cost of their print
per page and that's important because
even though
inkjet cartridges are less than laser
jet cartridges
they don't print nearly as many pages
and then for each of these people will
have to compute their expected pages per
day
so susan is only expecting 15 per day
this is the number that you will
actually print per year and so you'll
need a formula
to calculate that number once we know
the pages per year we can estimate how
much it will cost per year because we
have a
and then the total printing cost will
come here at the bottom
the total printing cost added to the
initial purchase cost
will give you the actual cost for the
two years of epsilon
and so your job is to figure out some of
the formulas that would make these
numbers make sense
once you're done you will highlight the
final result and you will create a chart
that will show the differences in each
of these printers
similar to the other problems we're
going to have a section for susan
and then we'll copy the information for
to the right side and we will
compute tim's numbers and so you should
have two charts when you're done
and find out what the recommendation is
for each of these people
welcome to the last in the series of
excel problem solvers
on this video susan and tim are asking
us to help them purchase a car
susan says would you help me pick one of
these three cars
i want to spend as little as possible i
want to drive the car
until it has miles
when i assume it will be nearly
worthless
i drive about thirty thousand miles
every year
thankfully i have enough money to save
so i don't have to borrow money and pay
interest on a loan that would cost me an
extra forty percent
let's see the three cars that susan is
considering
first of all she has in mind the chevy
spark
it's a small engine that gets good gas
mileage she has to pay fifteen hundred
dollars a year in
insurance the initial cost for taxes
is fourteen hundred fifty and every year
she spends two hundred and ten dollars
for a license
compare the other cars they have higher
numbers for each of those
so the ford mustang is 31 000 the gas
mileage is much lower
the insurance and taxes and license are
all higher
her third choice is the escalade
certainly a luxury car with a price of
000 low gas mileage high insurance
high taxes and high license fees
just how much more will that be than the
other cars
we'll find out when we make the bar
graph to compare the total cost of
ownership for
all of these cars tim said he would also
like to buy one of these three cars he
wants to spend as little as possible
he's going to drive the car until it has
000 he drives 30 000 miles a year so
everything so far is the same as susan
however the difference is he does not
have enough money to purchase the car
and so to make things simple we are just
simply going to add 40
of the price of the car to his
spreadsheet
so that will include all the interest
and bank fees
now let's look at the spreadsheet to
solve this problem
on the left side we have susan and all
of the calculations that we need to come
up with a price for which one is going
to cost the most
we'll put the cars in column b c and d
spark mustang and escalade the yellow
section at the top
will talk about the initial costs so
this is the price that she pays the day
she buys
the car she has to pay the original
price plus taxes
the more complicated question is how
much does it cost to own this car
every year and there are three costs
that we need to add together
we have insurance license and gas
how much are we going to pay for gas
that's a more complicated question than
just looking at the price at the pump
we have to know several things and so we
have a blue calculation
area from row 12 to 16.
first of all we need to ask the question
how much
does she drive how many miles every year
what is the miles per gallon or the mpg
for her car how much is she paying for
gas
and then we will know how much she pays
every year for gas
add those three together and we will
have total annual costs
insurance plus license plus the gas
now the question is how much is this car
going to cost
over the entire lifetime of the car well
first of all
we know how long she wants to drive she
said 250 000 miles after which we will
assume that the car has
basically no value left and she can give
it away to a friend to find out how long
the car will live
we have to ask how many miles does she
plan to drive each year
what is her goal which is 250 000
and then we can use those two numbers to
find out the total lifetime
expectancy of the car finally we will
arrive
at the bottom where we get the
calculations for the annual
cost of the car times the number of
years that we expect the car to live
we add in the initial price of the costs
and we have a
total lifetime cost of the car it might
surprise you
that you'll see the numbers up in the
range of where you expect to pay for a
house
down a little further we will calculate
the final
answer in row 27 and 28
we will calculate the average cost of a
year
so we know how long the car expects to
go how many years it expects to go
we also know how many dollars we have
total
and so now we can find out what each
year will cost for the spark mustang and
escalade
highlight these last three numbers with
their labels create a bar chart
and you will give susan some good
information on how much more it will
cost to buy luxury cars
on the right side of the equation we
will have tim
tim is going to be calculating almost
the same values
except him doesn't have any money saved
and so the initial cost of his car
is going to be 40 percent higher than
what susan paid
and so that 40 percent includes all the
interest and bank fees
so everything else should be the same
he's driving the same number of miles
and he expects to go 250 000 before the
end of life
and so when you're finished with tim
you'll have a similar graph
but you might find his expenses quite a
bit higher than susan because
he doesn't have enough money to pay for
the car in cash
congratulations you've made it to the
end of the course if you've
survived this long you have gone from
the beginning
to an expert person in excel now i
appreciate you spending the time
and if you're interested in these kind
of things check out my channel on
youtube my name is shad slooter i'm a
professor
at grand canyon university in phoenix
arizona i not only teach with excel but
i teach
programming so you can learn how to
build software websites
and mobile applications so thanks for
joining me
and best of luck with what you've
learned here